on est transporté c'est vraiment
merveilleux c'est au goût de quelque
chose qu'on n'a jamais goûté avant l'un
des liens se créent
l'amour que le medad dans notre mollet
il va se refléter nocivité seront
comblés petits cochons ses fils et mon
dieu s'est trémoussée chocolatées une
sauce dont on ne connaît pas l'origine
exacte mais qui prend ses influences de
divers pays le mot les pubs l'anneau est
une tradition au mexique d'un groupe si
le plan des mariages au mexique il est
mauvais c'est un plat typiquement des
rois kaka mais il faut savoir que dans
plusieurs villes du mexique
il y à différents de recettes dans la
ville d'iwaki lexus est res est la base
de la plupart c'est la main donc des
piments est plusieurs films 1 nous avons
été beaucoup de fumeurs chaque piment
amène son petit je-ne-sais-quoi une
saveur différente plus fruité plus
piquante peluche mais on commence à voir
un peu les colorations mais non tu m'as
n'est pas devenu noir
c'est très sain pour tenter n'est pas
bleu n'ont pu main puisque quand on les
brûle il dégage un goût amer est sorti
tout les sérums développent humain le
mollet en fait il ya plusieurs paiements
les principaux sont le goillot qu'il
prend le plus commun du mexique qui
donne une belle couleur rouge l'autre
c'est le moulin tos un piment qui est
très gros hr noirs à peau noire et qui
est des goûts de pruneaux et même de
chocolat donc il est indispensable
un boléro blanot le dernier c'est
celui-ci qui est le passilla mexicain
qui est un long film en noir qui ont
également savoir plus végétal si on peut
dire et qui donne une belle couleur
noire à la source
les piments sont la base du mollet mais
il y a une multitude d'ingrédients qui
le composent et bien sûr les recettes
sont aussi variées qu'il y a de grand
mère mexicaine
le mot votre sauce guacamolé c'est une
sauce à l'avocat alors des mollets y en
a des centaines
le mollet pour blanot qui le plus
célèbre la grande star de tous les maux
les contient au moins trois sortes de
piment sec des épices une multitude de
raisons comme des tomates des oignons de
l'ail défaut des tomates vertes
d'autres légumes une multitude de noix
qui peut varier du sésame des noix de
pécan des amendes des noisettes des fois
et bien sûr à la fin un morceau de
chocolat pour arrondir la sauce et les
recettes varient énormément d'une
grand-mère l'eau c'est toujours quand
elle est en train d'écrire des petits
mots parce que ça fait tous et toute la
famille les piments sont quand même et
pc assoira qui prépare justement la
recette de sa grand mère fait griller
tour à tour les piments et tous les
ingrédients pour ensuite les faire
tremper dans de l'eau chaude
un petit belle eau bouillante et si nous
savons enfin baguette pour aïn benian
parce que à la texture v notre sauce un
peu j'étais en même temps notre tortigue
nous avons ici un bel âge dammam et des
cacahuètes sens elles toutes les saveurs
commencent à se mélanger c'est surtout
notre ville commence à être assez
coûtera 7 est-il on va mettre tout
nothing étienne dano de mélangeant
le mélange des odeurs de tous ces
ingrédients en bon de la cuisine
ainsi nous allons rajouter non mais
large et pise le laurier mais mexique m
et les épices comme le poivre la
cannelle et l année sont évidemment
espagnol à yolande d'essonne et fait
intéressant les mecs qui sont les plus
grands consommateurs de cannelle au
monde
ça prend des piments ça prend ma canne
elle s'apprend de nice après ça on
entend le les variations tout au long de
la préparation de la sauce on fait cuire
des morceaux de poulet ou de dinde ce
qui nous donnera aussi un bouillon qui
permet d'ajuster la consistance au lion
des poulets on va t'amuser pour
s'assurer que l'on pâte lisse et nous
allons ajouter notre hymne dédiant bsb à
se presser les chocolats on peut donc le
constater
contrairement à la croyance populaire le
mollet poblano n'est pas une sauce au
chocolat sa belle couleur vient plutôt
du mariage des piments grillé le
chocolat ajouté à la fin donne de
l'onctuosité à la source quand les gars
la portion des chocolats qui on retrouve
dans la recette on peut pas parler de
poulets au chocolat mais les chocolats
bien quand même donné cette société pi
ses goûts sucrés qu'on peut retrouver
parce que normalement on ne met pas des
sucres et dans notre sceptre des panamas
s'arrête au bout et notre chocolat va
venir jouer cette rolls des secrets il
faut qu'il ya un équilibre de goût y'a
rien qui doit dominer un bon mollet et
cas qui ne seraient pas ce qu'ils sont
en train de manger on devrait être
capable de dire ce que dedans ça devrait
être délicieux
servir avec un bon rit beaucoup de sauce
et bien sûr des tortillas août c'est
complexe la petite ligue 1 qui arrive
qui est l'homme et qui portent trop fort
désir s étonne vous entrez secret épicé
et honteux surtout ce n'est pas sale et
c'est vraiment un bel équilibre est de
savoir parce que c'est à votre goût bien
évidemment je pense que marama sera fier
c'est que le prénom de votre grand-mère
léonard bender not as well it
[Musique]